in this video we're gonna talk about
when the stratosphere gets nasty and
touch on what I do for my PhD now if you
didn't catch the previous video on the
stratospheric polar vortex you can check
that out over here
or if you just like a refresher and I
highly recommend that you do watch that
video because we're gonna be carrying
right on from where we left off last
time so last time we characterized the
polar vortex as this big mass of
rotating air over the Earth's poles
which traps freezing air high latitudes
and it varied in strength so the strong
of the polar vortex the better
constrained that cold air was whereas if
the vortex would grow weaker than
there's a greater chance of that ultra
cold air escaping down to the lower
latitudes now we could get a measure of
how strong the polar vortex is by using
something called the Arctic Oscillation
index which is actually a measure of
surface pressure over the Arctic and
it's more complicated than I'm making
out to be but let's just leave it at
that for now the important thing is that
if the AO index is positive then the
vortex is strong and the cold air is
well constrained to high latitudes
whereas if the AO index is negative then
the vortex is anomalously weak and so
there's a greater chance of cold air
spilling out I bring this up now because
it's going to be useful later on in the
video but just remember that the AO
index is a measure of vortex strength
and it has to do with the surface
pressure at the Arctic so now let's go
back to answering a slightly more
fundamental question we talked about the
fact that the vortex varies in strength
but we haven't asked the question of why
in varies and strength on short
timescales we already talked about the
fact that the temperature gradient from
the equator to the pole controls the
strength of the vortex and ultimately
when it breaks up but it's variations on
a shorter temporal scale so variations
over short periods of time depends on
another kind of wave that we haven't
talked about yet gravitational waves the
sound is very physics that's complicated
right
gravitational waves are hideously
complicated subject I can't claim to
fully understand but what you need to
know for this video is this wave
transmit momentum in exactly the same
way that a physical object like a ball
which is moving transmits its momentum
by moving from one place to another and
if you've ever been on the beach and
felt a water wave break on you you'll
know that the fact that it transmits
momentum is true you can feel a really
substantial force pushing on you it
breaks and in exactly the same way that
there are water waves on the surface of
the ocean which it gets checked by the
Earth's gravity there are also waves in
the Earth's atmosphere kept in check by
the Earth's gravity they're just a lot
more difficult to see and while water
waves are caused by wind blowing on the
surface of the ocean and that forces
counteracted by gravity going downwards
atmospheric waves are much bigger in
scale and so they tend to be caused by
much bigger things like the rotation of
the earth and mountain ranges displacing
air upwards but in exactly the same way
as water waves gravitational waves in
the atmosphere also transmit momentum
and when they break they deposit their
momentum wherever they happen to have
propagated to and because of a few
geometric factors if gravitational waves
in the atmosphere break near the polar
vortex they deposit their momentum in
such a way that it acts to slow the
vortex down it basically acts as a brake
on the system and this happens all the
time
what can vary though is how much fit
happens at a given time because if
enough momentum is deposited in this way
then the vortex can be slowed right down
to a halt it can even reverse direction
and when that happens we get a pretty
significant event in response to a huge
amount of braking force from atmospheric
waves the polar vortex tends to do one
of two things
it either gets displaced from the pole
or it splits into two smaller dotter and
vortices but in either case what we see
accompanied this event is a very sudden
and very significant warming of the
polar stratosphere and when I say very
sudden we're talking over the scale of a
few days but on the scale of something
as big as the polar vortex
pretty sullen and when I say very
significant we're talking 20 30 40 even
50 degrees Celsius of warming these are
colossal
violent events and they're called sudden
stratospheric warming
although I prefer the original name in
the scientific literature they were
originally called explosive warming's
which sounds way cooler but it's kind of
less accurate the warming part of the
event comes from a rapid descent of
stratospheric air which then adiabatic
lee warms and that's caused by the
vortex slowing down all of a sudden and
having the stratosphere be much warmer
and less mobile than it used to be has
all kind of implications for how air in
the stratosphere moves around but also
has a lot of interesting implications
for how air in our layer of the
atmosphere and the troposphere behaves
remember the Arctic Oscillation index
that we talked about at the start of the
video that was a measure of vortex
strength and we form by looking at the
pressure the surface in the Arctic well
instead of looking at the pressure at
the surface we could equally be looking
at the pressure at any layer in the
atmosphere a kilometer above the surface
for example or 5 kilometers or 20
kilometers and we could construct an
Arctic Oscillation index for any height
that we so chose which would give us a
measure of how strong the polar vortex
is influences at that height kind of I'm
simplifying but bear with me now a few
years ago my supervisor did this and
look to how the Arctic Oscillation index
varied at different heights in the
atmosphere after extreme events in the
stratosphere like southern stratospheric
warming and what he found was this there
seems to be a descending influence from
the stratosphere into the troposphere
blaggs
overtime of the sudden stratospheric
warming and in subsequent scientific
papers it was found that this descending
influence impacted surface weather in a
few different ways such as where
Atlantic storms tends to make landfall
in Europe and this was significant
because up until this finding it was
generally thought that these
stratosphere which is much less massive
than the bulky troposphere didn't
influence surface weather at all in fact
it was the other way around the
troposphere would do things and the
stratosphere would react to it it was
like a lid to our atmospheric
circulation it wasn't really thought
without important for weather prediction
but this result and the subsequent
papers that followed on from it show
that that wasn't really the case and
that at least in the aftermath of
extreme events like southern
stratospheric warming the stratosphere
did have an influence on our surface
weather so as we talked about in the
second video if we can understand how
the stratosphere influences the
troposphere then we can use
stratospheric information which tends to
be much more predictable in the
troposphere to create better surface
weather forecasts and look further into
the future with greater reliability good
question at the moment this is the
frontier of our knowledge there are a
few theories flying around which explain
how the stratosphere can influence the
troposphere mostly involving a complex
variable called potential vorticity and
how that changes in response to sudden
stratospheric warming but there is no
one concrete theory which has been
proven against data and so there's no
one concrete way to improve our surface
weather forecasts my PhD involves me
testing two such theories against one
another the damage control hypothesis
and the plunger hypothesis which I've
had a fairly large role in
mathematically expressing and seeing
which one of them if either of them does
a good job of predicting tropospheric
anomalies in the aftermath of these
extreme stratospheric events and how we
can use that hypothesis to improve our
surface weather forecasts at the moment
though it's too soon to say if either
the theories will perform well and it's
entirely possible that everyone in the
field is barking up the wrong tree but
in the next couple of years I hope to at
least get a partial answer to
stratospheric troposphere coupling or at
least to thin down the possibilities of
what to consider though most likely it's
going to be several years before this
particular conundrum is solved
completely
so in this video we went really deep
into the stratosphere and looked at how
and why the polar vortex varies in
strength and how we measure that
strength using the Arctic Oscillation
index we looked at how gravity waves
deposit momentum and slow the polar
vortex we looked at the Sun warming's
that the deposition of momentum causes
and also looked at how the stratosphere
influences the troposphere and the
ongoing mystery of how that happens and
a little bit about how my PhD tries to
answer that question next time we're
going to take several steps back and
start looking at the atmosphere on a
global scale again looking at the
physics behind global warming and
climate change and why carbon dioxide is
the hottest compound around thank you
for watching if you'd like to support me
and this series then you can do so on
this courses Kaunas page which also
gives you a greater educational
framework can you can track how far
through this course you are and if you
did enjoy the video then please do like
it and consider subscribing to this
channel for more educational content
okay so here's my workbook it's
important we're good it's a book I like
books and it's got the work in that's my
laptop which has got the scripts with
crash course videos and that's my
Japanese peace lily always important to
keep that around because it keeps the
air oxygenated